there hasn't been a quiet day here since
the War
Began Russian Artillery he says never
stops once a week Ukrainian firefighters
run food and water to hundreds of people
a Lifeline for those still living in the
southern town of
oriv her home destroyed Ludmilla has
been surviving underground for more than
a
year the front line may be no place to
live but hundreds like her say they'd
rather die in their Hometown than risk
living on the street somewhere else
caring for her disabled husband and a
dozen other elderly
Neighbors The Strain is difficult to
hide I'm praying to God for survival I
just want to stay alive all I'm thinking
is I want my husband myself my children
my grandchildren as many people as
possible to survive we'd even live in a
hole in the ground I want peace I'm
tired on the southern front the gravity
of this war has shifted to places like
this oriv is a small town all but
emptied out since the War Began but
right now it has taken on an outsized
importance for Ukraine it sits at a
Crossroads just kilometers from where
Ukrainian forces are trying to drive a
wedge into Russian
lines
Yuri is making repairs to what is left
of his home before the rains come
Russian shelling leaving every home on
his Street in
Ruins craters now a part of the
landscape he struggles to talk about
it everything is painful it's painful
going to bed and painful waking up you
are living but it's hard on the soul
walking looking
around we had a life
here maybe if I was
younger but I'm already
60 maybe if I was
younger life on the front line the
constant
fighting the feelings of isolation
fatigue and
Trauma
relying almost entirely on deliveries of
food
Aid it would be a humanitarian
catastrophe people here would not
survive without water and
bread on a map it may look like
Ukraine's counter offensive is moving
slowly but on the ground in places like
this the pace of fighting has left no
building
untouched once home to thousands now
just a few
hundred unable to let go of the only
home they've ever
known Zan basravi Al jazer oriv in
Ukraine's southern zapara
region make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer